right the propaganda right are you with
me yes and propaganda is what is what
wins elections but when you take a step
back like Tucker Carlson walked away or
was fired but walked away right and you
step outside of the Matrix as you would
I would Tate or anybody else we we're in
The Matrix but we can step out and go no
this is what's really going on and we
voice our opinions where
ostracized for it isn't that funny but
we see the reality and so I always tell
people look take your emotions out of it
take a step back follow the money see
what's really going on and you'll get
the result right yeah so
um and you know I just think that if
people will do that I think they're
going to have a better outcome